scientists have used paper and string to
make a centrifuge that could be used for
medical tests in remote locations the
centrifuge is an important part of
science labs across the world in health
care you need one to separate blood into
different parts for further testing but
centrifuges are traditionally bulky and
expensive and need to be plugged in in
the quest for an affordable electricity
free centrifuge scientists have
previously made use of a salad spinner
but this design is relatively slow now
scientists Stanford have been inspired
by a simple children's toy that can be
made out of a button or a disk of paper
they studied the mechanics of the toy to
work out how to achieve the fastest
possible spin the final design can spin
at 125 thousand revolutions per minute
which is over two thousand spins a
second just 90 seconds of spinning is
not to separate a blood sample into red
and white blood cells platelets and
plasma a longer spin separates out the
part of the blood needed for malaria
testing named the paper fuge this device
costs just 20 cents to make out of paper
fishing wire in wood or you can 3d print
plastic versions in bulk
field testing in Madagascar showed just
how easy it is to use the device which
means that even remote areas with no
money or electricity could soon be using
the paper fuse to perform basic but
vital medical tests
[Music]